INFAMOUS CHATEAUMARCH MONT.
WE HAVE THIS FIRSTHAND STORY
COMING UP.
FIRST LET'S TURN TO A TOPIC THAT
MANY DEMOCRATS ALWAYS LOVE TO
POLITICIZE AND WANT TO TALK
ABOUT, ESPECIALLY EVERY TWO AND
FOUR YEARS, AND THAT'S RACISM IN
AMERICA.
SERIOUS TOPIC.
MOST AMERICANS, THOUGH, ARE NOT
RACISTS.
MOST AMERICANS DEPLORE RACISM.
THEY SEE PEOPLE FOR WHAT THEY
ARE, AS IGNORANT, HORRIBLE, E
EVIL PEOPLE.
WE KNOW THEY EXIST IN THE WORLD
BUT NOT THE MAJORITY THANKFULLY.
MOST PEOPLE WANT NOTHING TO DO
WITH THESE PEOPLE.
BUT FOR THE LEFT, THE DEMOCRATS,
AS WE HAVE CHRONICLED MANY TIMES
ON THIS PROGRAM, WE KNOW, WE CAN
PREDICT EVERY TWO YEARS AND
EVERY FOUR YEARS THEY WILL PLAY
THE RACE CARD SO THIS THEY CAN
WIN ELECTIONS AND NOW,
UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S GOTTEN
WORSE.
IT'S NOW BECOME AN ALMOST DAILY
OBSESSION, A POLITICAL WEAPON
THAT DIVIDES THE COUNTRY.
THE LEFT SEES RACISM AROUND
EVERY TURN, BEHIND EVERY WALL,
INGRAINED INTO EVERY SYSTEM OF
OUR COUNTRY AND ALL THROUGHOUT
OUR ENTIRE SOCIETY.
THE ONLY PLACE THEY DON'T SEEM
TO NOTICE RACISM IS WHEN IT'S A
DEMOCRAT OR INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHERE IT DOES
EXIST.
FOR EXAMPLE, NOW THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE A SLIGHT MAJORITY IN THE
U.S. SENATE, THEY ARE OPENLY
REFERRING TO THE LEGISLATIVE
FILIBUSTER AS RACIST.
THEY ARE CALLING THAT A RELIC OF
JIM CROW USING THAT ANALYSIS A
LOT LATELY.
WE DID OUR RESEARCH.
DEMOCRATS USE THIS SO-CALLED
RACIST JIM CROW RELIC A WHOPPING
806 TIMES SINCE 2001.
ALMOST 600 TIMES IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS.
IN FACT, THEY USED IT MORE THAN
REPUBLICANS, MAY MORE THAN
REPUBLICANS.
APPARENTLY, IT'S JUST RACIST
WHEN, OH, REPUBLICANS DO IT.
NOT WHEN DEMOCRATS DO IT.
WE SEE A SIMILAR TREND WITH THE
GEORGIA ELECTION BILL.
FOR EXAMPLE, LED BY STACEY
ABRAMS RAFAEL WARNOCK AND YES
THE EVER WEAK, FRAIL,
COGNITIVELY STRUGGLING JOE
BIDEN, DEMOCRATS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WITH THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA MOB BASICALLY HAVE
ACCUSED THE ENTIRE STATE OF
GEORGIA OF BEING RACIST.
REPUBLICANS IN THE STATE OF
THEY'RE CLAIMING THAT
GEORGIAIANS HAVE DISENFRANCHISED
MINORITY VOTERS WHEN JUST THE
OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
AND KEEP IN MIND THE STATE OF
DELAWARE, JOE'S HOME STATE WHERE
JOE'S REPRESENTED PEOPLE OVER
8,000 YEARS, THE VOTING LAWS ARE
FAR MORE RESTRICTED.
HE'S NEVER LIFTED A FINGER TO
MAKE THEM LESS RESTRICTIVE.
TO MAKE VOTING MORE ACCESSIBLE
IN HIS OWN STATE.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
GEORGIA MANDATES SEVEN DAYS OF
EARLY, IN-PERSON VOTING.
DELAWARE HAS NO IN-PERSON EARLY
VOTING.
IN GEORGIA, ANYONE CAN VOTE
ABSENTEE, BUT IN DELAWARE YOU'VE
GOT TO MEET SEVERAL
REQUIREMENTS.
IN GEORGIA DROP BOXES FOR
ABSENTEE BALLOTS THEY'RE IN
EVERY COUNTY.
IN DELAWARE, THEY HAVE ZERO DROP
BOXES FOR ABSENTEE BALLOTS.
AND, GUESS WHAT?
BOTH STATES, INCLUDING JOE'S
STATE, REQUIRE VOTER ID.
DELAWARE'S RUN BY DEMOCRATS.
IT'S JOE BIDEN'S HOME STATE.
HE'S REPRESENTED THEM FOR, OH,
CENTURY AFTER CENTURY, AND
APPARENTLY DELAWARE'S VOTING
LAWS ARE JUST FINE AND NOT
RACIST AT ALL.
AND THEN THERE'S DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR SHELDON WHITE HOUSE OF
RILED.
HE'S FREQUENTLY BEEN LECTURING
AMERICANS ON HOW THEY CAN BETTER
ROOT OUT SYSTEMIC RACISM.
BUT WHEN SENATOR WHITEHOUSE WAS
ASKED ABOUT HIS FAMILY'S
MEMBERSHIP IN LET'S CALL IT AN
ALL-WHITE BEACH CLUB.
THIS IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
YOU DECIDE.
>> HAS THERE BEEN ANY ATTRACTION
IN THAT?
ARE THERE ANY MINORITY MEMBERS
OF THE CLUB NOW.
>> I THINK THE PEOPLE RUNNING
THE PLACE ARE STILL WORKING ON
THAT AND I'M SORRY IT HASN'T
HAPPENED YET.
>> AN ELITE ALL WHITE WEALTHY
CLUB AGAIN IN THIS DAY AND AGE,
SHOULD THESE CLUBS CONTINUE TO
EXIST?
>> IT'S A LONG TRADITION IN
RHODE ISLAND AND THERE ARE MANY
OF THEM AND I THINK WE JUST NEED
TO WORK OUR WAY THROUGH THE
ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
>> Sean: A LONG TRADITION THAT
YOU ARE A PART OF AND WON'T GET
OUT OF.
IF A DEMOCRAT BELONGS TO AN ALL
WHITE CLUB, IT'S JUST A LONG
TRADITION.
THAT'S YOUR ANSWER?
WE HAVE ISSUES TO WORK LOU?
HOW MANY YEARS HAVE YOU BEEN A
MEMBER OF THAT CLUB?
BECAUSE IF ANYBODY WATCHING, ANY
REPUBLICAN SAID THAT, THEY WOULD
BE TARRED, THEY WOULD BE FATHER,
BY THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA
MOB, AND THEY WOULD BE CANCELLED
ON THE SPOT.
BUT IT GETS WORSE BREAKING
TONIGHT FOX NEWS.COM HAS
REPORTED THERE'S ANOTHER ABOUT
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE WHO BELONGS
TO ANOTHER ALL WHITE CLUB THE
LOCAL YACHT CLUB.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR SENATOR
WHITEHOUSE, I GUESS FORTUNATELY,
HE'S A DEMOCRAT.
HE'S GOTTEN A FREE PASS, HE'S
GOING TO REMAIN GETTING A FREE
PASS.
NO DEMOCRAT IS GOING TO HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO CALL HIM A
RACIST?
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DEMAND HE
STAY OUT OF THE WAY.
ANYWAY, IS HE STANDING UP FOR
ANY AFRICAN AMERICANS BY BEING
MEMBERS OF INTO IS CLUBS?
WHAT ABOUT THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
LAWMAKER DIE RON SDMONLD HE WAS
DENIED ENTRY INTO THE
CONVENTIONAL BLACK CAUCUS.
I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS THE
CONVENTIONAL BLACK LIBERAL
CAUCUS BUT THE CBC IS
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST CARR
AFRICAN AMERICAN, IN THIS CASE,
MR. DONALD, BECAUSE OF HIS
POLITICAL BELIEFS.
HE'S A REPUBLICAN.
HE'S A CONSERVE TICHLT HE
RELEASED A STATEMENT AND HE HE
WROTE, QUOTE, AS A YOUNG BLACK
MAN WHO GREW UP IN THE INNER
CITY OF BROOKLYN NEW YORK IN A
SINGLE PARENT HOUSEHOLD, MY
ACHIEVING OF THE AMERICAN DREAM
WOULD BE A VALUED ADDITION TO
THE CBC AND ONE THAT SHOULD TRAN
SEND POLITICS.
HE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
APPARENTLY THE CONTENT OF HIS
CHARACTER IS NOT ENOUGH FOR THE
CBC.
THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS
FRANKLY SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES BUT SADLY WE HAVE ALL
SEEN THIS MOVIE PLAY OUT MANY
TIMES BEFORE, MOST RECENTLY WITH
SENATOR TIM SCOTT OF SOUTH
CAROLINA.
WE SAW IT HAPPEN WITH CLARENCE
THOMAS.
WE'VE SEEN IT HAPPEN PRETTY MUCH
TO ANY AFRICAN AMERICAN WHO IS A
CONSERVATIVE.
MEMBERS OF THE CBC, I GUESS AS A
REQUIREMENT YOU HAVE TO BE A
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT.
AND CLEARLY THERE'S NO TOLERANCE
FOR ANY DIFFERENCES POLITICALLY.
IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT, RACISM
APPARENTLY IS TOLERATED.
LOOK AT THE RILED SENATOR.
IF YOU'RE A REPUBLICAN, IF
YOU'RE A CONSERVATIVE, YOU ARE
EXCORIATED, YOU ARE CANCELLED.
YOU ARE BEATEN UP BY THE MEDIA
MOB, BY BIG TECH, BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
PERFECT CASE IN POINT IS JOE
BIDEN, AND I'M GOING TO GET TO
HIM AND EXPLAIN HIS HISTORY WITH
RACE IN A MINUTE.
LET'S LOOK AT THIS CRITICAL RACE
THEORY DEBATE IN THE COUNTRY.
HOW THIS ANTI AMERICAN BELIEF
STRUCTURE ROOTED IN MARKSISM
CLAIMS WHITE PEOPLE ARE
COLLECTIVELY ALL GUILTY OF
RACISM FROM BIRTH JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE WHITE.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO TEACH THIS TO
EVERY STUDENT AT EVERY SCHOOL IN
AMERICA.
THEY WANT THEM TO LEARN THIS
RADICAL IDEOLOGY FROM AN EARLY
AGE.
SCHOOLS THAT CAN'T EVEN TEACH
KIDS READING, WRITING, MATH AND
SCIENCE, YEAH, THEY CARE
SEEMINGLY MORE ABOUT POLITICAL
INDOCTRINEATION.
PARENTS IN LOUDOUN COUNTY IN
VIRGINIA ARE RIGHTLY TONIGHT
OUTRAGED, THIS KIND OF FAR LEFT
INDOCTRINEATION IS CREEPING INTO
THEIR SCHOOL SYSTEM.
YESTERDAY THE SCHOOL BOARD SHUT
DOWN ALL PUBLIC EXCELLENTS AT
THEIR LOCAL MEETING, TWO MEN
WERE ARRESTED.
ONE FOR SIMPLY REFUSING TO LEAVE
WHAT WAS AN OPEN SESSION FOR
PARENTS.
THESE PARENTS HAD EVERY RIGHT TO
BE WORRIED.
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO BE
HEARD, ESPECIALLY ON DEALING
WITH CRITICAL RACE THEORY AND
OTHER FAR LEFT IDEOLOGIES.
WHAT IS THIS NOW, YOU KNOW,
SOCIALISM CLOAKED IN RACE,
INDOCTRINATE EVERYBODY INTO
GROUPTHINK AT A VERY EARLY AGE?
THE END GOAL IS WHAT?
HOW DOES THIS HELP BRING AMERICA
TOGETHER?
IS THIS DIVIDE AMERICA OR DOES
THIS BRING US TOGETHER?
DOES THIS REFORM AMERICA, OR
DOES IT DISMANTLE THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM?
I'M NOT SURE THAT'S GOING TO
WORK.
THIS COUNTRY SUCCEEDS WITH
SOMETHING CALLED FREEDOM AND
INDIVIDUALISM AND CAPITALISM,
AND PERSONAL FREEDOM, NOT
COLLECTIVE GICHLT NOT JUDGING
PEOPLE BY THE CONTENT OF -- BY
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN, BUT BY
THE CONTENT OF THEIR CHARACTER.
WHAT THEY ARE TEACHING AND WHAT
THEY ARE PREACHING IS THE AND
HIT THE SIS OF WHAT MARTIN
LUTHER KING DREAMED OF, THAT WAS
A COLOR BLIND SOCIETY, ONE THAT
DID JUDGE PEOPLE BY THE CONTENT
OF THEIR CHARACTER NOT THE COLOR
OF THEIR SKIN.
DEMOCRATS THINK THEY'RE IMMUNE
TO RACISM THEREFORE THEIR
BELOVED CRITICAL RACE THERAPY
CAN'T POSSIBLY BE RACIST?
MAKE NO MISTAKE, DEMOCRATS ARE
ANYTHING BUT IMMUNE TO RACISM.
NOW, REMEMBER, DEMOCRATS, THEY
ELECTED THIS GUY AS PRESIDENT
LESS THAN A YEAR AGO.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MADAM PRESIDENT, WE HAVE
PREDATORS ON OUR STREETS.
>> THE LARGEST GROWTH IN
POPULATION IS INDIAN AMERICANS
MOVING FROM INDIA.
YOU CANNOT GO TO A 7-11 OR A
DUNN KIN DONUTS UNLESS YOU HAVE
A SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
I'M NOT JOKING.
>> WHAT KIND OF A CHANCE WITH A
NORTH EASTERN LIBERAL WITH JOE
BIDEN STAND IN THE SOUTH?
>> BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
YOU DON'T KNOW MY STATE.
MY STATE WAS A SLAVE STATE.
>> WE GOT THE FIRST SORT OF MAIN
STREAM AMERICA WHO IS ARTICULATE
AND BRIGHT AND CLEAN AND A
NICE-LOOKING GUY.
THAT'S STORYBOOK.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO PUT YOU ALL
BACK IN CHAINS.
>> WE HAVE MORE QUESTIONS.
>> YOU GOT MORE QUESTIONS, I
CAN'T WAIT.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM FIGURING
OUT WHETHER YOU'RE FOR ME OR
TRUMP, THEN YOU AIN'T BLACK.
>> Sean: SO JOE GETS A PASS,
WHY?
BECAUSE HE'S A DEMOCRAT, A
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT?
TODAY I PENNED ANOTHER OP-ED TO
THE NEW YORK TIMES OUR FRIENDS
BEN SMITH MAGGIE HAS BEENER MAN
NEED TO GIVE BACK THE PULITZER,
OTHER JOURNALS AT THE NEW YORK
TIMES ARE NOT JOURNALISTS THEY
ARE RADICAL GREEN DEAL
SOCIALISTS.
THEY'VE NEVER COVERED BIDEN'S
RACIST PAST.
THE TIMES CONCERNED WITH BIDEN'S
PRIOR WORK IN THE SENATE WITH
SEGREGATIONISTS?
HE WANTED TO STOP THE
INTEGRATION OF SCHOOL AND STOP
SCHOOL BUSES.
DOES THE NEW YORK TIMES APPROVE
OF BIDEN'S EULOGY OF THE FORMER
KLANSMAN ROBERTS BIRD WHERE HE
PRAISED ROBERT BYRD AND HIS
INCREDIBLE 'EM STEAM?
DOES THE NEW YORK TIMES THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT BIDEN
OPENLY WORRIED THAT A SENATOR IF
WE HAD INTEGRATION OF SCHOOLS IN
AMERICA, THAT OUR CHILDREN WOULD
BE GOING TO SCHOOLS THAT ARE
RACIAL JUNGLES?
HIS WORDS.
IS THE TIMES AWARE THAT JOE
BIDEN COAUTHORED THE 94 CRIME
BILL AFTER REFERRING TO INNER
CITY RESIDENTS AS PREDATORS ON
OUR STREETS?
DO THEY CARE ABOUT ANY OF THE
RACIST RHETORIC FROM BIDEN THAT
WE JUST PLAYED?
DO THEY CARE THAT HIS SON HAS
USED THE N WORD AND MADE MANY
ANTI ASIAN SLURS HIMSELF THAT
JUST BECAME REVEALED IN THE LAST
FEW WEEKS.
OR DOES NONE OF THIS MATTER TO
THE NEW YORK TIMES OR THE REST
OF THE MEDIA MOB JUST BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN IS A DEMOCRAT HE GETS
A PASS.
NOW, ULTIMATELY MOST ON THE
LEFT, THEY DON'T REALLY CARE
ABOUT RACISM, ONLY IF THEY CAN
POLITICIZE IT.
LIVES MATTER, BUT ONLY WHEN THEY
GET TO POLITICIZE IT.
FOR THEM IT'S A MEANS TO AN END.
ON THE LEFT, RACE IS A POLITICAL
TOOL.
THEY USE IT TO TAKE DOWN THEIR
ENEMIES.
THEY GIVE A PASS TO THE PEOPLE
THAT SHARE THEIR VIEWPOINTS.
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT JOE BIDEN
EVEN UNDERSTANDS ANY OF THIS.
HE WAS QUITE CLEARLY STRUGGLING
AGAIN COGNITIVELY AND NOW HE
DOES, YOU KNOW, WHATEVER HIS FAR
LEFT MIND WANDERS ASKS OF HIM.
TRUE TO FORM THEY PUT JOE IN A
MEETING TODAY WITH A BUNCH OF
PEOPLE HE DIDN'T SEEM TO
REMEMBER AND WHEN JOEY, SIPPY
CUP, TRIED TO BLAME GUNS FOR THE
RISING VIOLENCE IN AMERICA'S
STILL HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
>> TRACE ILLEGAL GUN SALES BACK
TO THE SHADY GUN DEALER AND HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
POLICE CHIEF MURRAY OF THE
BALTIMORE -- EXCUSE ME.
POLICE CHIEF MERRICK.
POLICE CHIEF MURPHY, PAUL, OF
BATON ROUGE, LOUISIANA, TALKED
ABOUT ATTORNEY GENERAL GRENELL
OF NEW JERSEY AND OF MIAMI DADE
TALKED ABOUT THEIR EFFORTS TO
LIFT UP THOSE KINDS OF -- THEIR
KINDS OF COMMUNITY PROGRAMS TO
REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE.
>> Sean: DID ANY OF THAT MAKE
SENSE TO